Stranger Things fans suspected from the start
that El's number eleven tattoo meant she was
just one of several test subjects experimented
upon at Hawkins Lab.
And Season 2 confirmed that with the appearance
of Kali, aka number Eight.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I want to delve deep into some hidden
clues you may have missed in Season 2 which
reveal secrets about more young people likely
abducted by Hawkins Lab for experimentation
and who may appear in Season 3 and beyond.
Obviously, I'll be discussing spoilers from
both seasons, so take care if you're not up-to-date.
Kali and El's tattoos suggest there are at
least nine other test subjects in Project
MK Ultra.
And given that the lost sisters, who spent
time together in the Lab's Rainbow Room, have
different powers to each other, with Kali
being able to cast illusions, we can assume
the other young people subjected to the Lab's
experiments may also have developed different
abilities.
Although Kali herself doesn't mention any
other Hawkins test subjects, Eleven learned
about her lost sister when she read her mother's
mind and investigated further with the files
her Aunt Becky gave her.
And it's in those files that we get some glimpses
of news reports about abductions and missing
children and mothers.
Kali's file was among those papers so it's
very likely that Eleven's mother thought those
reports were connected to Project MK Ultra
and the Hawkins Lab.
The first file that Eleven flips past is a
news clipping about a Cleveland girl who's
gone missing in Indiana.
The report states that a 16-year old junior-high-school
Honors student and girls-basketball team captain
from Ohio went missing at some point after
leaving an Indiana junior-high gym to go back
to her bus that was returning home.
There's no date on this clipping, but it's
eerie that this potentially has a connection
to the ending of season 2 where we see the
Shadow Monster in the Upside Down looming
over the Hawkins Middle School gym.
The news report also states that the girl's
father is a widower, so she has a missing
mother, and her father describes her as a
genius and exceptionally strong for her age.
This could mean her mother was experimented
on at Hawkins or elsewhere, and after leaving
the MKUltra project, gave birth to a girl
with special gifts.
The mother could have later died from the
effects of the experiments, but the Hawkins
Lab learned about the gifted girl and abducted
her while she was visiting Indiana.
There's also another intriguing possibility,
though, which is that the girl was actually
playing basketball at Hawkins Middle School
itself, where we know there's a portal that
both a Demogorgon and Eleven used to cross
between the Upside Down and the real world.
Well, if this girl was gifted like Eleven,
she might have stumbled across the portal
and travelled to the Upside Down either willingly
or accidentally, where perhaps she got lost.
Or maybe she even created that portal in Hawkins
Middle School in the first place?
OK, so if that's not crazy enough yet, there's
more in the clipping.
The news report continues, mentioning that
a girl matching the missing girl's general
description was later discovered wandering
around an Indiana suburb.
There are various possibilities here.
One is that this girl was abducted by the
Hawkins Lab but she escaped and they managed
to find her and take her back to the facility
before she got to safety.
Another possibility is that the Hawkins Lab
guys arranged for a similar-looking girl to
be seen in the neighbourhood as a way of trying
to hide the fact that the real girl had gone
missing or they could simply have had Kali
use her powers to cast an illusion, making
it look like the girl was still out there.
Remember, they've done these kinds of things
before, for example, releasing a fake dead
body for Will to cover up the fact that he'd
gone missing in the Upside Down.
Alternatively, another pretty far-fetched
possibility, which may have sped through your
mind if you're a fan of The Flash TV show,
is that the Upside Down is a replica of our
world, just that's it's been corrupted by
the Shadow Monster.
After all, we see the same buildings from
Hawkins in the Upside Down, so could there
have been doppelganger versions of people
somewhere in the alternate dimension, and
a doppelganger of the missing girl was sent
to our world from the Upside Down?
OK, back to the other reports.
Behind the Cleveland clipping is another one
that only has some very sparse details.
The title appears to read "Another Girl Lost"
and you can see the words "go Police" mentioned
in the tiny bit of the report which is showing,
perhaps suggesting that the Chicago police
were mentioned.
If that's the case, then it looks like a Chicago
girl has disappeared too.
Another file which Eleven flicks past mentions
a baby boy abducted from a Memphis hospital.
The circumstances reported around the abduction
are particularly suspect as the account states
that the boy went missing with a nurse who
turned up for work unexpectedly after being
off sick for a week.
The article then states that the nurse was
discovered dead from a gunshot wound at her
house, but the boy was missing.
It sounds like the nurse was probably used
by the Hawkins Lab or MK Ultra project to
abduct the boy and then she was killed to
avoid her squealing.
The fact she was off sick and then suddenly
appeared at work may suggest she spent time,
either willingly or under coercion, at the
Hawkins Lab or another secret government facility.
It seems like the MK Ultra project were looking
for the child's mother because she was probably
an ex-test subject and they needed the nurse
to find out when or where she was going to
give birth.
The fact that the show's gone to the effort
of putting so much information and a photo
in this clipping makes me think this is another
gifted character which the showrunners could
be setting up to appear in a future season.
There's also something intriguing in another
newspaper clipping just behind the baby boy
article.
If you look carefully, there's some text about
someone missing from San Diego.
San Diego is, of course, in California, and
we know that two new main characters, Max
and Billy, moved from California to Hawkins
in season 2, though we don't know where from
exactly.
We do know that Billy has a lot of issues
though, some of which may be explained by
his authoritarian, bullying father, but we
don't know anything about Billy's mother and
why his father is no longer with her.
In some ways, Billy's introduction in season
2 was a bit sketchy and perplexing as he was
a real jerk pretty much the whole time, so
I do wonder whether the showrunners decided
to include him more for potential future storylines.
And, in fact, the Duffer Brothers have said
that they wanted to have a 'human villain
in the [show] that could disrupt the lives
of [their] characters.'
So, it's a long-shot, but I wonder if there's
any potential connection between Billy's mother
and this possible missing child or person
in San Diego.
There's also one more set of clippings which
are a bit more cryptic.
One says a mother and daughter from Pawtucket
have gone missing.
There's also a picture of a young boy which
mentions a county hospital.
And another article seems to talk about a
wave of disappearances of children and teens.
At the bottom of the piece, there's mention
of the Gary Police Department and Gary is
a small city in Indiana, not far from Chicago.
Now, I don't expect we'll see all of these
reported abductions or missing children in
future seasons.
Some of the children or adults may be dead,
long gone or not important for the overall
storyline the Duffer Brothers want to tell
in the show.
Some may also just be random reports that
are unconnected to the Hawkins Lab.
However, I do think that the missing baby
boy and the missing girls-basketball captain
are very specific and detailed reports that
I think we'll see feed into either season
3 or 4.
By the way, if you cast your mind back to
Season 1, you'll remember that, when Hopper
was reading newspaper articles about Dr Brenner,
one of them mentioned six subjects coming
forward to give testimony about the Project
MK Ultra experiments, and alongside that there
was a picture of young women dressed in the
kind of hospital gown we see El wear when
she first escapes from the Lab.
So, just as Terry Ives, who took part in the
MK Ultra Project, gave birth to a gifted daughter
in the form of Eleven, any of those women
in that photograph could also be the mothers
of similarly gifted children who'll appear
in the show going forward.
On top of that, given Kali's awesome power
to make people see whatever she wants them
to, there's the possibility that Hopper's
flashbacks to his last days with his daughter
are merely memories of illusions the Hawkins
Lab made him see, and that really his daughter
Sara was also one of the children abducted
and experimented on.
Something else I think is interesting is the
strong X-Men vibe to the show, which has been
clear since the very first episode.
Eleven already has powers reminiscent of various
X-Men like Professor X, Magneto and Jean Grey
and I wonder whether the Duffer Bros are considering
potentially teaming El up with multiple gifted
individuals like Kali and others out there
who we've yet to meet.
I love how the seasons have developed so far,
but if the Shadow Monster is going to be an
ongoing big bad, at some point I imagine it
will take more than just what Eleven can currently
do to defeat it.
It's possible that Eleven could continue to
power up, as she has done this season, but
it wouldn't surprise me if eventually the
monster's defeat ended up being a group effort.
So, what do you think about having more gifted
children or individuals showing up in future
seasons of Stranger Things?
And do you have any theories or predictions
on who they'll be and what powers they'll
have?
Let me know what you think in the comments
below and don't forget to also subscribe to
my channel for a chance to win an awesome
Stranger Things Funko Pop!
I'm currently working on more Stranger Things
plus Thor: Ragnarok videos, so hit the notification
bell to get my new videos as soon as they're
live.
And in the meantime, you can check out more
videos you might like here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!